[Musique]
las vegas la ville du vice la mecque des
enterrements de vie de garçon le royaume
des bars de danseuses et peut-être l'une
des capitales du machisme une image s'en
voit renforcée par hollywood seule image
qui contraste avec les femmes fortes qui
interprète la québécoise elyzabeth diaga
dans son spectacle queens of rock
présenté sur la strip
[Musique]
l'ex participante de l'émission la voix
s'est installé en résidence à de moselle
comme de strips une salle de 500 places
où elle présente son spectacle cinq
soirs semaine et dûment qui viennent ici
pour pour miser pour gan blé de l'argent
moi pour moi je venais ici pour me
dis-je mise un peu ma vie je me dis mon
ange vise je me dis ma passion et le
public est au rendez vous pour écouter
son hommage aux grandes dames du rock qu
un terreau petit lisabeth avec un talent
indéniable
l'état d'esprit est positif les gens les
gens en de revenir à la vie et ont soif
de spectacles qui participent beaucoup
vexé c'est positif même mangé un
charisme et québécoises et les québécois
dans une place et si des touristes
québécois sont plus nombreux à cause des
restrictions à la frontière des
expatriés de la belle province sont
nombreux parmi eux caroline lauzon et
même si on a fait virevolter chaque soir
dans les airs et les loin d'être une
femme objet c'est une femme forte qui a
réussi à faire sa place ici mais elle
avoue on peut pas dire que vegas soit
une ville particulièrement féministe ses
magasins donc c'est très jeune femme et
tout ça est comme si dia db au bord d'un
peu partout avec des femmes presque un
billet mais c'est ce que les gens
veulent c'est ce que les gens veulent
voir au cours de sa carrière il a
participé à quatre spectacles du cirque
du soleil interpréter 30 personnages et
même participer aux oscars en mars 2020
tout s'est arrêté
elle a alors décidé de devenir courtière
immobilière
les affaires vont bien parce que dans le
désert le marché surchauffe en une année
le 1er juillet il replongera dans le
spectacle au qui reprend la fiche mais
la super woman entend être courtière le
jour des acrobates le soir pour l'après
carrière mais vraiment l'amour de ma vie
c'est que sony soleil à jamais dans
cette ville où les clichés sexistes sont
omniprésents se cachent des femmes
fortes et talentueuse qui n'ont pas peur
de se retrousser les manches et de se
réinventer face à l'adversité
sinet bien alexandre chartier radio
canada las vegas